hey everyone welcome back to the walleye
podcast i'm james marshall
and this episode is brought to you by
what a lad coffee
yes last week we teamed up with the best
coffee bean in new zealand
and created the delicious water lad brew
it comes in either whole beans espresso
or for a plunger or filter
and it comes in three different sizes
200 grams 500 grams or go get yourself
the big 1kg this is a game changer if
you like your coffee
and if you're a lad head over to
pomeroys.com
or waterlab.com and go get yourself
a brew what a lad water brew also if you
enjoy the podcast it's not too late to
go get yourself some merch
and help this podcast grow anyway let's
roll today's
intro which is the same intro as always
now that we've got the start of super
rugby trans tasman underway i thought it
was time to get
one of my aussie legends on for a change
and who better than today's guest he's
played for the queensland reds
he's won the super rugby with the
waratahs and of course he's the closest
thing to becoming a wallaby
you will ever get as well as that he's a
london irish
legend and as all my guests are this guy
is an absolute lad one of the greats it
is brendan mckibben welcome kimbo thanks
for coming on mate
thank you thanks jimmy thanks for the
intro always love it i was anticipating
what you were going to say this week you
didn't miss a beat
[Music]
mate and you were right into it you're
right into that jingle too that's your
sort of tune isn't it i love the jingle
i think it's a great addition yeah
whoever's come up with that has done
pretty good yeah it is but anyway what
are you up to where are you
currently in sydney got a day off um
i'm coaching rugby at a school director
of rugby to school and also coaches
first 16 so
pretty time consuming but i love it you
love it you're back to where you belong
yeah i think so jimmy yeah yeah i am so
how was post rugby for you i know you
went straight into
coaching referees didn't you after rugby
so how was that and how'd that all
how did that transition all work out
yeah so straight
um it was basically six months before i
i retired i took a job at rugby
australia coaching referees
so as soon as i finished i already had a
job and basically left london irish two
weeks later i was i was in the
hq building here here in sydney so it
wasn't much of a break and it was it was
good because it was seamless
yeah i worked for them for almost uh
close to two years
and i got made redundant last year when
the new rugby australia
um restructure like they cut 80
something jobs and i was i was an easy
one i was sort of
last in first out type and you know a
business decision i would have done the
same
so um and then it took me you know about
six months to find a new job and that
was actually really tough
but the transition initially was pretty
seamless
but then going into the workforce and
going okay look i'm available during
covert
no no one no one's hiring but i've
landed i've landed on my feet now
which is which is nice oh you always
land on your feet you're one of those
guys but how is it coaching referees
because obviously you've never riffed
before
yeah i i found it interesting because
when i first came in i had some ideas
and i just wanted to
just to soak up as much as i can and
listen to these guys and the way they
talk about the game and the way they
look at the game is just so different
from what a rugby player is so i try to
bring
a rugby player's perspective to it get
them thinking okay
where should i stand what would a team
anticipate what a team might do to get
myself in the best possible
position to see and and just little
things like that and we spoke a lot
about the game the way they reviewed the
game is completely different
yeah and i think referee coaches in the
past
they're always getting told boys you've
done this wrong you've missed that your
business you missed that
so you know i know if i was if someone
came into my workplace it was sitting
telling me
every two minutes look he entered too
hard space bar should have been a comma
um working on your sentence structure
all the time you'd be you turn around
and you tell them piss off
yeah i know anyone would and so we tried
to
we tried to grab and harness the good
that the referees are doing and then
obviously have some
work ons as well so from a review point
of view and a preview point of view try
to
get them to focus on some positive
things for the match mate you sound like
a gun coach
that's unreal love that
and we still get it wrong
oh referees mate they're tough it's
tough because
they could referee the house down for 79
minutes they are
one decision away from potentially
ruining
ruining the game or ruining an
opposition for
a result and and so they they can never
switch off on the never drift
and that's really hard to do especially
when
you know they've seen something they
might have seen someone round the throat
or someone around
you know in around the face and then
they've got to
follow the play but they're actually
thinking about the previous but it's
hard to then
switch off and know what's next and get
what matters
and so the better refs are doing that
and some of those better refs are
ex-players how hard is it to actually
referee a game like
you talk about just one bad decision but
there's so many decisions
in a game of rugby that you have to have
to be on for a like it's literally such
a hard game to riff
exactly and the non-decisions are the
ones that actually matter so
getting it's getting what matters and
not making a decision
can actually benefit the game and so
okay yeah
he might have held him down in iraq or
it might have been
whatever it might be okay line out some
more that went a little bit early
okay i'm going to grab them on the run
because that's going to be a trend that
they're doing
rather than penalizing fellas if you do
that next time it's going to be a
penalty
what were your thoughts on the captain's
challenge that was introduced i loved it
i liked that i liked that though
it's different for the game and to be
able to use that
tactically is is really good i i i
enjoyed that
and you reference you obviously did you
ever want to get into refereeing oh i
look not actually refereeing because i
know how much they cop i don't reckon
i'd be able to do it week in week out
everybody hates you and you just
constantly cop the resilience piece of
the referees is pretty
it's pretty strong and it needs to be
strong and i um it didn't really
interest me to to be honest
i did referee a couple of games and
scary i loved it
i liked it i was like wow this is cool
this is cool
yeah because you're still involved you
still see the hits but you don't
actually make a tackle not that i made
many tackles in my
but you're close to it you're part of it
still
um yeah so that's that's that's the
aspect that i really like but
not week in week but what about you you
spoke about the refereeing
and how much they cop so you're
obviously around it all the time how
much sort of criticism do they get and
how do they deal with those it's crazy
it's a crazy amount and it's a scary
amount for some coaches so
some coaches who will get beat 60 to 10
send in 15 clips and you're like well
come on seriously have a look at
yourself
uh before clark laidlaw the great clark
blade law always used to say
don't never point the finger because
you've got you're pointing one finger
but you've got three pointing back
i really like i've used that actually in
my coaching um
and so yeah they do cop a lot
um and fair enough they're actually
pretty thorough
with their review and their
self-awareness is getting better so they
put their hand up and they say look yes
i've missed that or i've made a mistake
and they're actually functioning as a
team now not not just as
in the middle before when we came in um
a couple of exposure coaching they were
kind of like if it's to be it's up to me
you know i'm the man in the middle i'm
gonna make the decision but now their
leadership and working as a team
is evident each week they don't get that
decision right all the time
no well no one could but you were a big
part of like
banter and um did you still get that in
the refereeing and in your workplace now
or is that a big part of a rugby you're
missing
no i i don't i don't get it as much
uh in the school because
as you can imagine we're going to dial
it down a little bit we still do it but
we just dial it back in things that we
say and things that we do but
certainly i i did bring it to the to the
referees that were great again it was
sort of individual
they are in a team in a rugby australia
team they were individuals
and we tried to bring that team aspect
to it we think we got there
it was pretty good um things around
camps and dinners and
sharing information um but also yeah
giving each other a little bit of a
ribbing i certainly brought that in if
you can't laugh at yourself then
you know i don't want to put it on
others then i can certainly love it
myself
you were always good at that and you've
come up in a few what a land episodes
already
one blair cowan
[Music]
i actually listened to that episode and
that story he said was
cracking me up it was so true but
he did not touch me and i just kept
running but the thing is i'm milked it
afterwards
you know when you bait someone you they
get a little bit red missed and i was
just like he's gone here
and i just kept going and going and the
more i did
the harder he came back and he was
actually filthy at me he would have
talked to me afterwards
oh oh a couple of crack-ups
you were so good at it
oh i loved it was he the easiest for you
to get or see a few other guys who
used to find easy targets oh he's pretty
easy he's probably the easiest actually
um and i know you had a little bit of
involvement as well but like
even even the little things you didn't
even have to say anything
but blair in a team meeting because he
would stuff up his words a couple of
times
he knew his content he was perfect so he
knew everything and he knew what he
wanted to say
but when he would go to talk and all the
eyes would be on him in the front row
we'd all look at him
someone would just need to make a face
he would stuff up
going into a team meeting we were inside
his head like he didn't even have to see
[Music]
so that was a sweet spot yeah oh
god i used to love it i miss those
meetings with
with big blair cowan absolutely but mate
i do miss the changer in banter
yeah i like i was i loved it i loved
that
team room the on-field off-field
camaraderie um i remember a guy used to
say
oh look when we went to like an exit
meeting in the rpa and he said the big
thing you'll notice is your phone goes
silent and it does
well mine did got it
i i um i would get you know you get drip
fed messages and i'm still in contact
with a lot of guys
but instead of having 60 messages or
whatsapp messages in groups that you
normally part of each day
you know you go down to 10 20 a week
yeah
um where guys are just that amazing are
you checking in on each other
rather than the all the gifts flying
everywhere and
you know being part of that that's
something i did miss because i spent a
lot of time looking at gifts because i
wanted to get quality over quantity
now my wife just cops and she just
shakes her head
oh good times yes it is a big part of it
isn't it
that sort of camaraderie and banter
you're constantly getting as a rugby
player but
yeah oh i made this massive i mean
that's you go out and you go to
war with these boats every week every
weekend and your match day so
you've got to be able to get along
everyone talks about culture what does
that look like culture's different for
every every team um
yeah but but relationships are key and
that was a big one for me
ah love it anyway let's go back to the
start for
a young brenda mckibben i you sound
aussie you look aussie but you're not
aussie
where were you born and yeah i'm not a
i'm not an aussie
i'm a scotsman i i was born in irvine
in scotland on the west coast and
migrated when i was three and a half
it's probably one of the greatest things
my
parents have ever done they went out on
a limb
and they moved my sister and i when when
i was three and a half
um over to australia and they said look
we're going to give each other two
two years our family we're not we're
regardless of how hard it is two years
we're going to stay in australia i think
within the first couple of weeks they're
like we're set they moved we moved in
late uh late october early november
so it was a hot time of year and they
were like wow how good is this
normally it's freezing cold and dark in
scotland and
and i've been so grateful because i
don't know what i would have turned out
to be
if i stayed in scotland um or what i
would have done
but i was so grateful because i had
opportunities
never spoken about land or space or
weather
so much but you certainly notice it when
you go to the uk so
really grateful for that and and loved
it because i was exposed to
so many different sports and a lifestyle
that i probably wouldn't have got
in scotland so what sort of sports did
you play growing up
everything yeah i always played a little
bit rugby league my dad loved football
so i played soccer
um i was into swimming during school and
but everything everything was like what
my mates did as well
and that's that's that's a big part of
it like your mates
your mates at school they're like oh
we're doing gymnastics you go and try on
gymnastics because
you get invited to a birthday party you
know the kid's birthday my head goes
this
and the kids are talking about a
birthday party he's like i want to be
part of that okay i'll go play rugby
so my um the kid who i was in primary
school with
george good good little friend of mine
don't know george anymore but
let's track down george yeah
that's our last stop he'll be somewhere
so
so george got me into play rugby and i
went down to ashgrove jeeps as a junior
and i was playing rugby in rugby league
as well um and then i stopped playing
regularly because
all my mates were playing rugby at jeeps
and and that's where
i started playing rugby as a a
five-year-old and never looked back
real yeah you've always been very
energetic even now
like i know you're an energetic guy were
you like that as a kid were you just
into everything 100 wouldn't stop
wouldn't stop like
if they were to diagnose adhd
back then or it would be it would be
evident i would be on medication
i should i'm sure all my teachers would
have said get this give this guy
something to calm him down
um what my mom used to do she used to
put me
you know some kids who are on the reins
yeah like your dungarees i used that mum
used to put me in dungarees and she used
to put the reins on my back when i go to
the shops
just to keep me close um now i think you
can use electrical
stuff like that but yeah you invented
the lady
oh goodness me uh mum tells a story of
like i don't
i don't really remember it but it was
you know the tomato ketchup were in
glass bottles back in the day
and there was a stand
and it was like a promo you know you get
at the end of the aisles anyway
i swiped the tomato sauce bottles
probably
you know hip hop so the whole thing came
down
mum was so embarrassed it was i'm pretty
sure
i was red not from the tomato sauce but
from my mother um
woke up two weeks later but yeah that's
uh i think that was the end of my
shopping
edition the start of the lead
oh mate i could imagine you you would
have been
i was into everything i think that's why
my parents put me into so much sport as
well i was like how am i gonna tire this
guy out what do we do
i think it's a great way um not only to
tire someone out but
for kids to go and experience all
different types of sports yeah so when
did rugby become sort of an idea that
it could be a profession for you man he
wasn't it wasn't really an idea that
it would be a profession at all maybe i
was like
17 and i got the contract oh i got the
reds
reds academy contract um because
i i was making all like the queensland
sides and all that when i was younger
queensland 16s
queensland 18s and then 19s it was then
um but i was a flanker
and then i finished school i still got
contracted as a flanker of the reds
academy
and then eddie jones was the coach there
of the reds at that time
and he said mayor i can't sign you mate
you're too small
and so i um so i was like
okay that that's kind of me done i love
rugby i love playing
with my club brothers and he said look
you can he can't beat a half-pack me
he cannot be half so he got me to change
and he took me to saracens and
i just threw passes i went over there
and changed from seven to nine and
and that was it what do you mean he took
you to saracens like was that with was
that a contract he was he coaching them
how did that work yeah he was after the
super rugby season they did all the
contracting and they let me know they
said look we can't sign you because
you're not big enough i wasn't tall
enough and i wasn't weighing enough and
any weight that i would put on would
have to be
was going to be bad weight just because
of my um physique
and so they said okay you try halfway
you know you'd be great
nippy you're everywhere you fit um and
passing was a constant work on
and eddie then got the sack from the
reds and he went to sarri's head coach
so he took me over these guys look i'll
bring you over on a six-month trial
because
the super rugby finished in july and
didn't in pre-season that didn't start
up to late december yeah so he said come
for six months
and i did and i passed and i passed and
i worked with
moses raloonie and the and this skills
coach then was paul gustard i just
worked with them so much and
at the end they offered me a contract
and they said look
we'd like you to stay we think you've
you know improved remarkably we'd like
you to stay what do you reckon
i couldn't do it i was so homesick
i was so homesick and i just emailed the
reds back and said look
they've offered me to stay i'm pretty
homesick you know is there anything you
could do and they offered me
a contract on a wider training reds
contract as a nine
sure i left there six months ago as a
seven they offered me
as a nine ben whittaker sent me that
email i'm like i think it was the
22nd that evening on the 23rd of
december i went into eddie and i said
look they've offered me something i
can't do it i want to go home
and they put me on a plane within like
six hours and i was at heathrow
on my way home i got home for christmas
oh wow it was awesome
it was so good yeah i was so homesick as
a as a young fella yeah
i was so homesick and it was so good to
be home and then
and then you know six days six days
later seven days later i was starting at
the reds as a nine
gee what a turnaround day six months of
passing
and you've turned yourself from a world
class seven to
world class nine yeah yeah i don't think
i was well
yeah i know what you're saying so then
you were back at the queensland reds
you're you're now a nine
how was that going into that environment
oh it's good it was really good there's
a guy called will
will genya he was there he was the
younger guy he was
yeah he's all right and sam cordingly
was finishing up
oh yeah um and nick berry actually had
just left
the referee you know yeah he just left
to go to go overseas
so just trained and worked hard i
just had to keep working on my past
decision-making and knowing when to kick
when to run and when to pass because
my balance was all off i was just
thinking contact
yeah good dummy go dummy go
and then you know i got tired quickly
because i was getting belted
and then being eddie eddie taught me a
lot around the balance of picking your
moments and
and when to run kick and pass and and
the queues on that and so
that helped a lot but it was a constant
work i think the club that i played for
brothers was the one that accelerated me
it promoted me
to to really get that get those
professional contracts because
i enjoyed my time at park footy at
brothers
and we were successful yeah it helps
when you're winning but we had a bunch
of guys who just
loved the razzle dazzle we would it was
head wobble everywhere
you would have been very very proud
yeah well you say that they got you
there but i mean 223 points from you
that first club season you're playing
for them that is unbelievable number
goal kicking playing half that just
scoring
points at will wow you pulled that stat
out yeah 223 did you say that's a huge
amount wow
i didn't realize i was that cool yeah no
it was
it was a good it was a good season we
scored a lot of points
club footy's the best jimmy you're
playing at three o'clock in the
afternoon
um great crowds hostile crowds throwing
the ball around
so um yeah i loved it and it helps yeah
it helps when you're winning
but because i was i love going to
training on a tuesday thursday
saturday the banter and all that is um
it really did help promote me i think
and then you got a wee taste for the
reds
debut against the chiefs how was that
one i was nervous
i was really nervous especially playing
the chiefs but
how good for it to be the narrative of
making your debut against the kiwi side
at home
and in front of your friends and family
and all your mates
and so that was awesome that was great
came on
and they were like oh you're goal
kicking as soon as you come on you're
goal kicking so
we came on score to try uh not long
after guilty
and then i i was able to kick and that
settled my nerves once i was able to
kick a goal bang i felt
oh i'm part of this but before that i
was so out of my depth i've just felt
like
i was i was out of my delta i shouldn't
be here and you know and people always
tell you oh no you've earned the right
you should be here and everything
but until you actually play until you
actually feel that you can prove
something in yourself yo
you you don't well i didn't feel like i
belonged
yeah i was going to write a training but
you know who's not good at training
um you try things at training but it's
the ability to be able to do it on the
on on the pitch
and um you know i just focused on my
bread and butter
just the passing the kicking and all
that and the goal kicking when i came on
it helped and once
once i was able to do that i was settled
and i was like well
this is pretty cool and i want to do it
more so it was infectious once you get
your first cap
yeah did you always were you always
comfortable goal kicking was that a big
part of you
obviously um to on debut to be goal
kicking that
for me that sounds like huge pressure
like this the last thing i want to be
doing is kicking a goal straight away
but you obviously
enjoyed that and you felt comfortable
once you were in that environment to
gold cap
yeah i did because i fell into goal
kicking
the guy brothers was like oh mate but i
don't really want to kick you kick
and so i was like okay started kicking
and then the kicking was actually going
all right
i didn't have much coaching but i did a
lot of it because i loved it
and then they were like okay
i was going all writer that you go kick
and and then that sort of settles you as
a player as well when it's one of your
strings to your bow
and you can actually you're actually
able to go and do it that settled me
because i was like oh great
there wasn't actually that much pressure
one some kicking coach once said to me
um anything in the in the 15s
non-negotiable outside the 15s
fair play and so i always took that
mentality nowadays it's not really like
that these goal kickers are unreal
but um that's what it was in 2008 2009.
yeah so where was that kick from outside
the 15.
i think it was just on the 15. oh yes
yeah what's that one negotiable or my
legs were shaking
uh no it went over it went over so i was
lucky i didn't hit it that well from
memory
um bit of a dead duck but got the point
it's a good sign of a gold kicker when
you don't hit them that well and they
still go through
but then obviously you moved down to
sydney what was that uh move about
they went down to sydney and new south
wales contacted me they liked what they
saw
and i i jumped at it queensland were had
a younger team
sort of rebuilding phase waratahs had a
lot of guys eric barnes and i
um went down there at the same time so i
was in chats with him he said may come
down it would be great
be really good and there were guys like
phil wall al backstar
like really old heads that i i was
looking forward to going playing with
luke burgess was the current wallabies
nine and he was at the waratah so
so nice to be able to go and learn and
lean on his experience and he was great
so did you get much game time or you
straight back to club rugby carving up
yeah went straight back to club rugby
and carved up you've probably got your
stats there how many points i scored
that you jim you don't know
all i know is that you got club player
of the year play a long long way
they stopped counting halfway through
the season
the referees decided oh dude that player
of the year
yeah they give a three two one so it
must have been all right with the
referees
or some of them quite you're a bit of a
nauseous to the rest weren't yeah well
did you were pretty
good um i i was a bit of a nause in
general but i'm not so much to the
referees because as a nine
i always knew that the referees are
going to make the decision so i'd be
like even if it was
the most horrific call and i knew he got
it wrong and be like
and then the one time the one time that
i asked for a penalty or something blew
up they'd be like
oh yeah yeah and you know i might get it
no wonder you got all their votes
it's all about playing the game yeah
i'll rock up to the game and tell him
how good he's looking you know
three points
oh goodness but yeah and then and then i
made the i was playing some games
um for the waratahs the following season
and that was again nervous do you fit in
should you be here with those guys you
train with them you train well
you're confident in your own game but
playing you don't want to let them down
that was my biggest thing you never ever
want to let your teammates down
and until you actually play you don't
know did you feel like once you'd played
that sort of
completely went or was that sort of
lingering with you throughout your
career
throughout my whole career throughout my
whole career to the very
last game um wow my biggest fear
was to let my teammates down to do
um to make a bad decision or a wrong
call
i i did i did a kick once
in the we played the waratahs played the
reds and it was the last
minute or last like 30 seconds i didn't
realize what the time was on the clock
like just in experience
nine not knowing and we'd practice all
see
all pre-season you know space in mind
you know guys call it nines don't worry
you just react one guy called a kick in
behind
bang i didn't even think i just reacted
put the ball down
time was up when the reds got the ball
they went a couple of phases
ran 80 meters scored the length of the
try and we lost it
like i have nightmares still about that
i cannot get that
out of my head i'll be driving on like
for a long drive or just randomly
having a shower and that pops into my
head like
and it kills me it really does i'm like
oh how do i how do i get this out of my
head but i can't because i can still see
the kick i feel the kick
and my and the feelings afterwards that
i've just let
a whole squad and my teammates down like
it's just
it's it sucks yeah so did that ever stop
you from putting yourself in a position
where
um you might make a mistake you know
like you had an opportunity to
potentially go for something
but the fear of failure was too much
that you thought
you'll just play the safe option yeah i
reckon sometimes it definitely did
where i probably wouldn't have backed
myself to
run as much or or maybe to execute that
kick
that i just passed now that pass is all
right because you
you just see it and the coach sees it
and everyone else sees it and they go
yeah that's just a pass
but what i could have done to influence
the game i probably didn't
because of that fear of failure now
i learned from that mistake and actually
then it became a real positive i knew
how to close out the game i
knew how to manipulate the sides but i
took that one
thing early on in my career that still
haunts me to the day
and every time the rents play the
waratahs massive rivals every time it
comes up on instagram they show it
as a reds miraculous victory i'm like my
mates always
tag me in it they always tag me and
they're like oh
brah remember this yes i do remember it
don't send it to me
[Music]
i joke about it but it actually it
honestly kills me i hate it
i've got hot flushes talking about it
now
oh the brutal realities of a rugby
player right like you're always under
yeah you're always under the microscope
one mistake like that
has obviously haunted you for what extra
what 10 15 years whatever it's been
yeah yeah no seriously yeah it has and
um
the thing about that uh that pressure
it's not so much the pressure jimmy it's
the fact that i have a fear
of like letting those guys down
and that how much i can influence that i
mean yeah it's only a game in that but
still
i still like struggle to let that let
that one thing go
and that's probably the biggest one that
i can remember and probably one of the
only ones i was about to say because you
didn't often make mistakes and you did
have a really good career at the
waratahs so any highlights from you
waratah's time obviously
you won the super rugby title in 2008
what a year that was yeah that was a
great year so
probably two main highlights or three if
i was just to name three would be like
one my debut against the sharks it was a
sunday afternoon
cracking awesome awesome day for footy
and
waratahs have pushed so hard for a
sunday afternoon so
game and they don't normally do it
because of you know television rights
and everything
normally 745 kickoff but we got that
three three o'clock kickoff from the
sunday avo so perfect i was used to that
three o'clock kick off club games used
to the you know the process
perfect then the the other one was
probably playing against the lions
waratahs lions
british and irish lions this is not the
british and irish lions
yeah not the not the lions from joberg
no not those guys remember games against
those but
no the british and irish lions in 2013
just unbelievable the lead
up afterwards everything about it it was
it was really good that was special
and then the 2014 finals probably the
other highlight so talk to me about that
final
what a game that was right down to the
wire clutch moment from
bernard clutch moment and again
referee decision could have gone either
way the richie mccall
over out hour forward tolulatu
picked the ball up from the back of the
rock just a little pick and drive he was
kind of isolated he got tackled but
richie mccaul
went in for the pilfer his left foot was
probably yeah
it wasn't square but normally
you would let that go cragged you bear
straight on at waratah's benefit
um and the rest is history burning foley
with the kick
i was standing behind him at the key and
he goes ah
[ __ ] he thought he'd missed it and it
was the perfect
seven iron draw and it just came back in
and just wrapped
in that little t section of the uh
of the uh of the uprights um and then
yeah
that was it they kicked off kicked
probably a little bit deeper than what
they would have wanted to
for a get back kick we held on the ball
and that was it so it was awesome
you kicked it out and you jumped the
highest i've ever seen someone jump
yeah yeah it was pretty high i'm not
sure maybe like 10
12 foot or something but um yeah it was
really good it's such a special moment
for
everyone because every team works hard
you're like we get that all the teams
worked hard
but for your site to actually complete
something that you set yourself out to
do set the goals and work
so hard together um oh my the change
room scenes were awesome like
so people crying everyone cheering
people just sitting by themselves
soaking it all in and that was really
special we sat in the change room
for a while after just as a team just as
a squad
and staff and that was really nice sure
yeah
so that kick would have been right on
foley's range did you ever contemplate
um stepping up there and kicking that i
would have
if bernard yeah but he was confident
mate he's one of those tens that
so i kicked at the world ties and then
bernie came in and playing fallback and
then he came to tenney he was one of
those tens you know the tens are like i
need a kick
i'm going to kick for goal i'm going to
kick the line i'm going to do everything
and you know he had the confidence to do
that it worked great everyone called him
the iceman as well
um with the few clutch wallaby kicks and
so it was perfect but yeah i probably
would have stood up
oh andy dang that curly
curly was also there and so it would
have been interesting to see
if he wanted it or if he said yeah away
you go brendan but
anyway what do you reckon what's your
gut say have you heard it
straight
[Music]
just chunking it doing doing a
syndesmosis or something or
spooning it just taking a massive divot
you
[Music]
give me isolation for a year at least so
a couple of years earlier you were
called into the wallabies weren't yeah
do you want to talk to me about that
experience
yeah so started making some wallaby
squads just at the back end of the year
and the go away for the autumn
internationals and over in the uk
and was there thereabouts now there was
an
injury so i went over and um sat on the
bench for a wallabies test it was their
final test against wales
and nick phipps was the starting nine
and i was on the bench
and i didn't get on which is why um
everyone gives me a lot of ribbing once
we're nearly wallabies
but i can tell you what i warmed up i
was ready to go i did
so many laps in the in goal but
millennium stadium the crowd the anthems
it was just such a phenomenal experience
one i'll never ever forget i can
remember it so clearly
and i was like a yo-yo you know the the
manager
yeah i've become i've become so yep
i would have been so flat when i went on
the field because i suspended so much
energy in the end goal and then walking
up
up and down up and down people always
say oh you know the people just stay
measured on the bench don't don't ride
the emotion of the game just sit back
and watch what they're doing
know your role and your impact i
couldn't do it jimmy i was
riding every tackle i loved it and
but i didn't actually get on i was like
a yo-yo up down up down
and then final whistle blew and i never
actually i got to keep the jerseys which
is great but i never got that
one cat oh heartbreak which is a shame
was there a moment when you realized oh
i'm not going to get on this game no not
really because
even to the final kind of like last
minute we're currently feels good to try
in the corner yeah
i was in the box ready to go on
i think they were going to do the old
just away you go son just run on even if
it's for 10 seconds but curly beal ended
up scoring and then
the time elapsed and nathan sharp kick
kicked the goal in the corner
oh yeah so i didn't get on but
it was nathan sharp's last game victory
all that sort of stuff the experience
and i loved it i never actually
never actually thought oh i'm not going
to get on
um i thought i was going to get them and
you obviously being a part of the
environment for the first sort of time
did you feel like this was just the
start of what was to come with you and
the wallabies
yeah well there's not so much the
wallabies because after that jimmy i'm
not sure if you know i
um after that test uh scott johnson
reached out
he was he was scott johnson who's now
director of rugby at rugby australia
he was head coach of scotland contacted
said mate
mate can i come down and see you ah so
sorry
yeah fine so we had a massive night
after that
that final test in in cardiff he came
down to see me with his wife they drove
from scotland
we met at it we met he picked me up from
the hotel the hilton there and we went
to a local pub
sat and had a coffee and he's like mate
i want you to play for scotland true
would you consider it
and i was like what i'm just sat on the
bench for the wallabies
and he goes yeah you didn't get on all
that sort of stuff you don't actually
have a cat would like you to play you're
scottish born
come pick any side you can go and play
in the guinness premiership
if you want but you can choose either
edinburgh or glasgow if you want
sweet mate just come what do you reckon
and i said i'll have a think about it
he rang me back that afternoon and
everyone was like go for it barry barnes
is like mate
six nations rugby could you imagine
being involved in february six nations
um it would just be epic and i said
yep true very true so
i spoke to my parents and i was like and
my
my now wife my girlfriend i was like i
think i'm gonna do it
i'm gonna do it i'm gonna i'm gonna head
up i'm gonna get back pack my bags tell
the waratahs
that i'm gonna leave and uh and go to
scotland by the time i got back to
sydney i received
an email from scott johnson saying sorry
mate um i the international regular irb
have squashed this
they can't do it because your class is a
um australian international
what what what for not getting on for
not getting on
so i got the agent and all that sort of
stuff just to write an emails
and they said no if as soon as like as
soon as you commit to a tour or
something and i was like
i can we can provide so many examples of
this not happening
yeah and so i did i didn't um i didn't
end up going mate
in hindsight yeah that would have been
great but i wouldn't have won
i wouldn't have played against the lions
wouldn't have won a super rugby title
so um the decision was made for me
and and luckily enough i was able to
stay at the world house for a few more
years that's crazy i don't really regret
i don't regret it
i all i think about was like geez that
would have been different
yeah the story would have been different
and would i have liked it
probably i would have loved it because i
love playing footy yeah um it just would
have been a little bit different was the
fear of homesickness ever
on on your mind because you obviously
been over there before and did get home
so
this time around not even not it didn't
even think about it it was more the fact
you're seeing dollars you're seeing the
potential of what you're going to do
and you're like well pounds and you're
like i'm going
oh yeah yeah yeah so um
but it didn't end up happening so you're
back to the waratahs back with your good
mate michael checker
and winning super rugby titles yeah
exactly
yeah check's uh an interesting character
he was a great he was a great coach
for the three years that i had him um
a few a few good stories of it you two
got along well didn't you
yeah we did we got along really well
actually um you know i i loved him i
loved what he was about he's a hard
worker
he's past so passionate and um
you know i believed in him he and he
believed in us
so that was that was that's a good thing
about a coach and the relationships that
you have with
with the coach got a great story
yeah we liked each other a lot until
until this moment
no we we went over and we actually
played the lions in joburg you know
altitude we just won in sydney we went
we went over there and played in in
joburg
so altitude as you know in the warm-up
you're absolutely gassed you just
where's my second wind is it going to
come is it going to come we played
we played the lions and we were winning
the lions started to come home
and yucca creel was just um
running an absolute muk just a seven
with a motor that i've never seen
before yeah he was a beast and their
back line was just uh
so we're like oh come on you to put the
subs on be gonna put the subs on will
skelton was
was playing eight ball played 80 minutes
that game and he was like walking around
so kopi kepu was another one
and um the guys were tired and i was
like sure he's going to put our subs on
he didn't put about five of us on i was
one of them
and nick fibs actually had a really
really good game he's got a massive
motor anyway
so he he could have run all day but
it was one of those things as a player
you think you can make an impact to the
game
and because i was a little bit older
then i was like i was i was rapable
after the game so how's he gonna put us
on
how is he not plus oh avoid him don't
say anything don't say anything you know
just avoid him
and so change room afterwards i just
grabbed about 10 snakes and
go around the corner and eat the snakes
and drink power didn't need the sugar
but
still did it um and i wouldn't sit on
the sitting on the bus
and everybody was down because we
obviously lost the game and i was i
can't i can't see him i don't want to
say anything to him
anyway you know when you arrive at
joburg monte casino where you stay
they drop you off just before these
about it's probably like 15 stairs
and he dropped us off and the bus is a
front and a back door and i was
just behind the back door always and he
was at the front
and we sort of doors open walked off and
um he just like gave me this scale
scowling look
as we both met at the stairs to go up
came like this look and
i was like i said to him i was like
oh jackie you got a minute and he goes
what what do you want
and i was like oh yeah i just
saw red and i was like
mate send me home bring over maddie
lucas um
i want to go home and play club footy
you can bring someone else over and play
next week
um and he goes what
and i said yeah well if you've got a
moment to chat i want to ever talk to
you
and he and he's like i'm sick of selfish
blokes like you
asking my time in the house like what
you think i'm selfish i sat there and
sit there and don't say a word and the
moment i'm asking you for your time and
we started having like this argument on
the steps about three quarters away up
mind you the rest of the squad has to
walk up these narrow stairs
and we're standing there he's obviously
tearing over me and we start screaming
each other
and he's there going oh [ __ ] yeah you
can go home
no you're staying you're staying you're
not going anywhere
and um i was like fine i'll stay we kept
walking and he's like
no you're not going home and i was like
right i'm not going home i get it as i
walk up and he goes no
we can chat now and i was like oh so now
is a good time for you
people was like sort of looking back and
everything so we walked down out the
back of
the hotel was he we sit down and he's
like
may i love you like a brother what are
you doing to me and i
kind of just said look this is not from
a selfish point of view this is from a
team i thought
we could have added value if he made
subs we could have won that game
and he was kind of like look i'm the
coach i've got to fall on my own sword
i've got to make these decisions the
other coaches wanted to make the changes
as well
they wanted to put you on and i'm like
it's not about me it's about everything
and he's
anyway he's like let's have a drink i
don't want a drink i just wanted to get
this off my chest i wanted to talk to
you about it he was like
okay we're good yeah yeah so went out we
all went out as a team last night
that night everyone was talking about it
on the monday this is where the story
gets interesting
if it wasn't already interesting on the
monday he was just standing around
before training he's like yeah okay
six day dennis seven michael hooper
eight uh paulu
nine kibbo ten foley and
when he read out my name is nine
everyone like in the circle looked at me
and i was like oh my god
i didn't mean for that to happen i just
wanted us
to get in and anyway so the boys are
coming up
oh said it worked it worked out oh well
done
i said to nick fitz who was actually
playing well it's like mate i'm so sorry
he's like nah mate it's all good like
whatever like
after that training um i did most of the
reps as you do is
starting nine check it went up to um
fang and goes
i did he didn't do many reps are you
injured here okay
he goes oh you're named kimbo in the
starting lineup
and he goes oh [ __ ] what
he didn't mean to name me
so i i i would do the quick recovery as
you do at the pool downstairs
text the wife hey gus yeah i'm starting
yeah
great here good
teammate comes in my roommate dave
dennis he's like mate how good is this
you know you're starting whatever
get out of the shower just having a
shower knock out the door
yeah yeah yeah right hold on yeah i was
just driving myself knock at the door
give her open up i was like oh let's
check
to open up i'm bollocks naked open up a
paycheck
and he just puts his head against the
door and he goes
mate i [ __ ] up and he was like
sweating
and i was like oh my it's all good oh i
didn't mean for that to happen he goes
i'm so sorry i'm going for a whiskey
and i and boys the boys loved it oh god
did i cop heaps you know and they're
like i can't check you're going to
apologize to him you're going to
apologize to him he's like
[ __ ] apologizing he shouldn't be
started you know and then
turn it back on me um anyway turns out
that weekend
i got like 30 minutes or something in
the game and he put on all the subs so
it worked jimmy
it worked but uh i thought you might
enjoy that little checker story
but yes we are good mates we are but we
are still we are still
good was that the year you won it no it
was the following year oh
so you you sort of planted the seed for
the ongoing success the club was about
to have
well he left and went wallaby's
full-time coach but um
yeah i i don't think i planted any seed
in that man's head though
but i was living in his head on monday
selection
for a little for probably half an hour
until he realized that he actually
stuffed up and didn't meant to say my
name
oh goodness oh so good so then after you
won the super rugby
title you decided to head over to the uk
london irish
what was the reason behind that move
yeah i always wanted to go and play
overseas after that initial chat with
scott johnson and everything
i started to follow a little bit more i
never really followed uk footy but i
then i was like okay i actually want to
go and have a taste of this at some
stage
didn't know when that was going to be
turns out
um i could have gone a couple of years
earlier and then i didn't really feel
like
that was the right time 2015 i said look
we just won the super rugby title i'd
like to stay another year we made the
semi-finals that year got beaten by the
highlanders who ended up
going on to win it as you know um so
and then and then i went the following
year so it was perfect timing and i was
really happy
and was there any other clubs that were
an option or was it always london irish
for you
yeah there was a couple other clubs and
i nearly went to rgn as well in france
and i thought yeah yeah
yeah that would have been really good
but i always did think about
the premiership and followed the
promotion yeah i wanted to um
i kind of i liked what i saw because
and what i had read about it and trying
myself
the nines play a little bit differently
over there yeah and how did you find it
when you got over there
different mate daryl gibson was a was it
was my coach at the world house and
spent a lot of time in the uk and he
said look go over there
soak it up listen and shut your mouth
for six months
because they talk and think about the
game differently
not everything that you do in super
rugby is the right way
and they you'll certainly get a lot of
kickback if you try and implement that
so that's that's what that that's what i
did um
anyone tell you that when you came over
jim no i wish they did that's great
advice
yeah um so then i started to try and
drip feed some things in to try and
change and
and whatnot but it's um yeah they just
do they think about the game differently
they think
you know you can't go down the road four
hours on a bus
to win because they have a different
ground
i'm like what
[Music]
[Laughter]
you still you realize what um
the emphasis on home matches what sides
of the
opposition you're putting out how big
the squads are rotation
eqp all the rest of it plays a big part
and that's something that i didn't know
um prior to coming over what was the
biggest difference for a nine
kicking mate yeah
god kicking 17 times a game over in the
uk
and we kicked maybe three times a year
uh under michael chick under michael
checker the way we know we didn't exit
we ran everywhere we had an exciting
backline
yeah with some big names who were
devastating ball carriers so we're like
we'll just exit we'll just run it yeah
um
but exiting your own half in the uk
doing that as a nine contestable kicks
kicks for distance
field position big part of it are you a
very good box kicker so it did suit you
yeah look i didn't mind i love i love
bob skicking
and i like the exit strategy of how i
was then
able to manage that in game manager
because it was all on the nines there
where you were in the field how you
kicked what type of kick so i like that
because you've got more responsibility
and greater responsibility
rather than being a threat
threatening running nine and a
distributor
in super rugby and not much of a kicker
yeah
so you had mixed success over at london
irish though um
a few tough years and a few good ones
yeah that's the the tough years that
when you get relegated so
i got relegated twice when i was at
london irish and you get relegated from
the premiership have
all types of effects the first year was
the biggest one where
you get relegated yeah you keep your
contract head what's up still get paid
the same but you're playing in a
different league
that's disappointing in itself coupled
with the fact that you know we're
sitting there at training
and people are walking out crying on the
phone to their partners or families
because they've been made redundant they
lost their job because of what
your performance has been like on the
pitch so you had a
you know direct responsibility
for these people losing their roles and
that hit home to me i hated i felt sick
knowing the fact that you know i don't
even know how many people but
at least 20 plus lost their jobs because
we
as players didn't perform on the pitch
and for you to have a direct involvement
and that was pretty it was pretty hard
to swallow
pretty hard to look at and see because
you develop relationships with these
people they're good people
love rugby all of a sudden sorry
your team's crap they're staying they're
still going to get paid the same but
you're out um that's difficult
yeah it is brutal but then you obviously
uh rectified that and got them
um promoted straight away the following
year
yeah i would say we got them promoted
you and i
um jimmy oh what a partnership
what a partnership that was in the
finals in particular
wow well the finals is a funny one the
because you do the play off home and
away aggregate points
oh so weird you know you're going into a
final and you've you're seven you run
out and you're 17 points up
[ __ ] it's actually hard to get you your
head around
especially in the final after we did
okay in the actual final not the
semi-final
home in a way the final home in a way
and then we run out we play in yorkshire
and we we go up a lot
and not only on the screen doesn't show
your current score it shows the
aggregate
so you look at that you're like oh we're
45 to 12.
yeah we're going okay then we made
wholesale changes and the boys just
wanted guys frankie's name
they were just after francie
[Music]
him up and then it ended up being a
scrap and he was and he threw back
frank franks he got angry stone cold he
just unleashed
but that meant he missed the barbarians
he was filthy
he was kind of the barber i was like the
following week or the week after
he had and he missed it he missed a
payment of of his barber's cash so he's
pretty guilty of that
i'm sure he wouldn't demand it if it was
another league game but um
no i'm frank see how tight he is that
would have that would have cut him
well speaking of tight man there was one
that in particular that you got along
really well with jeff cross he's come up
a few times in the podcast
you must have some good stories on her
jeff cross
like honestly scottish international
titus cram
uh just a strange strange guy and
yeah so mate just just on that tight
story he we used to go
to a place called h a coffee coffee
joint after training
yeah anyone was invited you know you get
10 or so guys there
sitting having coffee drinking eating
schnecks
all afternoon they close at five o'clock
one afternoon
the lady came because you know you pile
so much money by into the till
she came and said oh do you want all the
leftover cookies just put them on the
table
jeff lived kind of upstairs of h like
diagonally upstairs
and um he was like he came in
so he came in after five o'clock he said
all these cookies were yeah they just
gave us all these cookies
so jeff proceeding that afternoon
would knock on their door at five
o'clock asking for all the leftover
cookies
not only that he would wait and go
downstairs to the tesco's which was next
door
he'd go to the and get the off milk
so you know used by date is like yeah
27th if
it's the 27th he'd go down there at 28
and ask for all that off milk and
wouldn't pay for it
really yeah how about is that
just put milk cheap
get back to the farmers give back to the
local farmers
oh goodness me did they give them as the
cookies
no no no no they didn't they didn't no
no they knew what he was up to crafty
character but another jeff story like
this is not mine but it's probably it's
from it's actually mike coleman so moo
moo lived with him yeah and uh he was
i think this is in edinburgh and he was
upstairs mike
was freezing and jeff's like wife was
like oh mike you know
do you want us to turn the heating or
you're cold my polite as they calm
no no no that's fine jeff just goes
don't worry
downstairs heating comes on at six you
know because he
rises so he never used to put his
heating on because he'd always just get
the heat from the floor from downstairs
oh he's a special special human that
like
well he must have saved some cash
throughout his rugby career
oh yeah i think so he definitely
definitely did
because he wouldn't shout he would not
shout and every anytime we go on social
would it
show socials you were only allowed like
your
beers everyone just uh boys just
grabbing bees he'd go and go
i'll have that whiskey please and he'd
have to top whiskey
the most expensive thing bathtub's gone
like that because jeff's had three
whiskeys
oh wow classic jeff yeah classic
mate one of the one of the perks of
being over in the uk is all the
places that you get to travel so many
spots just
hour flight or something away so any
good trips that stood out for you
yeah look i i went everywhere
because they told us that you know you'd
have a week off before you go tuesday to
sunday
oh my wife and i would just book places
we go anywhere
but one one particular trip that does
then um stand out was a chip
a trip to prague so i wasn't going i
wasn't initially going to prague it was
all the young kids that are going for
prague
cheap ass awesome nightlife have a
massive weekend
so they were oh what have you ever come
not any old blokes ever come and stuff
and i just said that to my wife i was
alright boys are giving it to me today
she said why don't you go was it what
this is the test is this a test
i said why don't you go and i thought
off yeah well
i should yeah what do you reckon i'll go
for a couple of days oh no i was only
going for one day
yeah because we were going to venice
later on oh yeah and i rocked up to the
airport and i saw i saw the boys because
i knew what flight they were on just
subtlety got that and
yeah so i booked a flight didn't even
book a hotel and
walked up to the airport and i like oh
hey where's wings you know
it's a hard voice i'm coming to prague
whatever where is she and now we're all
like having a drink before they hopped
on the plane
early in the morning and i was like nah
and i have my ticket
i'm coming to prague and they're like
oh god we had the best time but um one
story on that trip that
does stand out but without a few drinks
we've done a bit of bar hopping few
drinks
we're going into another pub and we're
going but boys it was a bit of a walk to
this pub
boys right we're on a charge we'll get
in there as quick as possible yeah more
points more pints all that sort of stuff
just as we were about to go in the pub
two dogs came two beautiful dogs
lady walker two beautiful dogs they rise
oh
greg and gilly awesome look at this um
and then everyone's down patting the dog
and louie's like yeah there's a pub
now so everyone's like we like school
children shut ourselves go in the pub
then then louie goes to the toilet
and we ordered drinks we were sitting
there where is he yeah
whatever he comes back and he sits down
and he goes to have a drink
and he has like has as a dream
as a drink of his pun he's like oh
he smells his hand he's like oh yuck
and he goes to steely he's a scottish
guy next year he was like
hey does that does that smell like [ __ ]
too
and he goes scott's here he goes that
actually smells like human
shape
he had chewed on his hands it was the
funniest thing
ever the story is really funny for me
because the memory in my head's funny
i'm not sure if it's that uh that funny
for you but anyway
um that was that was really good the way
that sort of
eventuated but yeah oh that's so nice
and yeah needed yeah
needed a bit more soap on his hands i
think that afternoon old louie
oh some absolutely that would have been
some trip
but anyway mate how did the career end
what happened so did you have an injury
what was what was the ending point for
you now i
um i was going to stay at london irish
for another year got contacted by a
couple of guys at rugby australia
in late november yeah and they said look
we've got this role this new role coming
up what do you reckon
no didn't consider it they called me
back two weeks later i said look please
if you've got five minutes bit of face
time
and they sold it they sold the dream he
said was this
my wife was about to give birth to our
first child in january
and i said to them if i was to take this
role i wouldn't be able to start for
another five months because i wanted to
finish off
the season and for london irish in may
and i did that they were happy to do
that and cover the workload i worked a
little bit
whilst i was in that five months and
and so yeah i just took i just took the
job and it was a perfect time for
to get my wife and the little fella back
um back to
australia around family and support
because that
over in england we didn't have anyone we
didn't have um
any friends or family oh sorry yeah we
didn't have any friends
no we had friends but um wouldn't have
any family or support to come here
which is always ideal when you've got
kids oh 100 or smart option
so that obviously wasn't a plan you
hadn't really planned to be a
rugby referee it just sort of all
happened did you have any plans
that you wanted to do or no look jimmy i
wanted to be involved in sport i knew
that
not necessarily rugby i'm involved in
rugby now but i didn't want to pigeon
pigeonhole myself in rugby um yeah so
i'm just finishing up my masters of
sports coaching but i i like the idea of
program structures the way coaches work
and trying to get the best out of
athletes so it didn't necessarily have
to be rugby it is rugby
but um yeah i like all sports oh geez
you're a lad
and what a career man some of the
oh some of the great stuff there but as
always we've gone to our instagram for
some
questions and brenda mckibben the almost
wallaby
he came up with tons i'll choose a few
[Music]
first question who do you look up to
could be taking a few ways this one
i like what you did there jimmy not many
people could do that just a little
subtle
but you're really good at those subtle
jokes anyway
um oh look as a rugby player
there was plenty a guy called david
croft and george smith as a young seven
always looked up there was also um i
hate to say it because i hated playing
the kiwis
because i always lost josh cromfeld oh
yeah
um yeah used to love watching him run
around but um
[Music]
yeah okay this one what is israel falal
like this interesting one
yeah um really really top guy phenomenal
athlete
probably the best player i've played
with it's a huge call too that
he is a he is an absolute freak yeah
he's so good
yeah yeah absolute freak and he was
really good around the squad yeah loads
of stuff has come up about
you know his twitter and we get all that
but
it wasn't he wasn't like that around the
guys he wasn't like that around the
group
he would be rea you know we had a team
tonga
islander huge islander connection they
would keep to themselves a little bit
but he wasn't influential
like you would see on his twitter he was
great around the guys
loved a bit of banter didn't go out as
much as what because he used to just get
smashed
but when we used to have socials and
everything it was really really good it
was always coming to them
um on the field you know that you know
you know that
um he it was freakish ability at
training you'd hate to get him in a
one-on-one
because he would just be he'd step jimmy
his step would be like five meters
yeah he's like a racehorse um and then
obviously in the air
it's just unbelievable greg thompson
remembers how good he
the greatest is oh goodness don't bring
that up
tonksy he's a nightmare it's probably
like my reds thing about that
um no you the old tonksy wouldn't have
much to do about that no
not many people in world rugby when his
aerial ability
yeah i don't know if you could be upset
about that i mean the guy's jumped like
three meters in the air yeah yeah he's a
freak it's called so many tribes for the
broncos and storm
yeah oh it's interesting interesting to
hear from a player who's played with him
because obviously
he does get a lot of i guess hate now
with
what he's come out with with his twitter
and stuff but to hear that he's not
actually
yeah he gets he gets smashed no he's not
he's not he's he was really really good
um as i said like nothing
he would never try and push anything on
he'd never have any judgment or say any
judgment around
anything and was really really good for
the squad
well that covers the next question
because it was the best player that
you've played with is ralph falau is the
answer who is the best referee in the
world
oh i don't really have an answer for
that one um
yeah at the moment i would say a guy
called damon murphy
australia he's coming up little redhead
guy he's good i'm only saying that
because he was my groom's
my wedding but um he's a rugby
australian referee
and he goes all right ben o'keefe is
pretty good um
so yeah the thing is with ref say you're
only one game away
from being the worst referee again oh
yeah and each week
each week you're getting smashed so yeah
it's really it is really difficult as
long as you
and players can adapt and they are
consistent
then you shouldn't have any issues but
there's always these unique things that
come up in games that
catches a referee out or a player or a
decision
or a non-decision yeah yeah tough deck
anyway top three aussie lads this will
be an interesting one
adam ashley cooper dave dennis and
curtly beal
wow what a crazy it's our golf golf crew
yeah isn't that definitely the top yeah
we've been to a few golf tournaments and
trips that have been quite a lavish trip
as you can imagine
oh wow need another one oh
goodness yeah so you guys don't play
anymore because you're a title
no we're just the stars having a line
both um adam and dave are
playing for the guillotines in mlr
yeah currently is it rating sure and i'm
just too hard
and i'm in anomalous school yeah but the
funds are there ready to go
we we put money into an account so we're
ready to go oh
yeah really yeah would you ever like if
a team offered you a contract could you
play now or
you don't yeah i could play now jimmy
i'd probably need to lose a few kilos
but i'd definitely
um i definitely wouldn't you wouldn't i
wouldn't play
nah i've um i've i've run my race i've
had my time
i i thoroughly enjoyed it um but even
now like
now that i watch i've been like oh these
guys
these are big collisions yeah these are
big collisions
and and and i don't and i you know as i
said i'm content with what i've done
fair enough because what a career it's
been okay next question this is to
comment about a video
the piggy and the princesses what a
video that is
on youtube oh what what what a terrible
video
um look that was a thing that was fox
sports back in the day
uh and they just now now media is a lot
better piggies and princesses
it's cringeworthy if i would ever see
that video again
but yeah you look so young in it
and your arms are massive well there's
something to do there with the
cinematography i'm sure because my
arms weren't massive but yeah i was
young certainly with it now after
um after having a bit of sun damage
but you you're in the kayak and you went
well in the kite you're just
yeah i was a beast in the kayak probably
because of those massive arms but
um i was no good with the trivia i don't
think i got one right
benny moen destroyed me from memory
oh one of the great videos i love it
okay two more questions if you ended up
in jail what would your friends and
family think you're in for
[Music]
oh goodness robbery yeah
yeah a bank a bank robbery
very detailed plan bank robbery
that would be yeah yeah oh man there's
some of the video like at the italian
job or something like that
where you'd be able to get away and yeah
i like that i love those movies
yeah or
or i'd go in there for murder um
because my wife and child were
um kidnapped all right like take it and
i'd be like liam ness oh wow yeah i'd
love to do that
you know just track them down yeah i
hope none of this happens yeah that's
a couple of good answers
[Laughter]
so many options
it was great to explore that type of
creativity i love that type of thinking
yeah okay last last question
best piece of life advice you've ever
received
[Music]
my mum always used to say there are
always people watching
be yourself all the time
yeah so i jesus nice
that's all i got
but what i would say from a rugby point
of view what a way to finish
to the list yeah rugby advice play
multiple directions
because it worked as a junior as it now
working in schools and seeing what these
kids are up to
people are fixated on being a 12 because
sbw is a 12 or a 7 or
their influential player who they look
up to so i would say
my advice to these kids coming through
play multiple positions and play
multiple sports because you don't know
how you're going to develop
you don't know what you're going to be
like when you're older
and versatility as being a coach now
versatility is key especially for
selection play anywhere
coach you're in yeah
you're in you're on mate great advice
life advice and rugby advice you nailed
both of them
one of the greats and or mate what a
career
what a journey that you've been on it's
been awesome to get you on the podcast
i've been wanting to get you on for a
long time
it's just awesome to actually go through
your journey what a journey it's been
scotland
wallabies stories stories from
everywhere london irish mate
it's been a hell of a career and i
obviously love my time playing with you
over at london irish
absolutely and uh always had plenty of
energy to
give to other people i always felt
energetic when i saw you mate you're the
energy that you brought to the team
so mate it's been awesome to have you on
the waterlap podcast and i appreciate
you giving
up your time please thank you you are a
lad
[Music]
led
[Music]
so